[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport
l'émission est considéré comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti pour le sommaire
football dans le championnat de
régionale 3 es trappe s'est imposé ce
dimanche 10 février à domicile votre
parisy sur le score de 1 but à 0
résultat qui leur permet d'espérer une
montée en fin de saison plus de détails
dans ce magazine
aviron thomas barrau kramer licencié au
cercle nautique de versailles a réussi à
remporter la médaille d'argent ce samedi
9 février au stade charléty de paris
lors des championnats de france indoor
une première étape vers les jeux
olympiques de 2020 nous le recevrons
dans cette émission arts martiaux le
maître le karaté naoki omis est venue
enseigner ses techniques de combat à
plaisir lors d'un stage organisé par le
karaté club isérois
une cinquantaine de personnes ont
participé à ce rendez-vous reportage à
suivre l'actualité sportive de la
semaine c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence par du football direction le
championnat de régionale 3 les
trappistes se sont imposés ce dimanche à
domicile contre eux parisi sur le score
de 1 but à 0 un résultat qui leur permet
d'espérer une montée en fin de saison
des images de mélanie poker montage de
xavier gens un but qui suffit à leur
bonheur les trappistes sont assuré
l'essentiel ce dimanche 10 février en
s'imposant 1 à 0 à domicile face à
paris-xiii dans une rencontre marquée
par les incidents en fin de partie des
conditions climatiques difficiles
il a réussi à développer un jeu assez
peu orthodoxes ont rebondi parce que les
terrains ne permettait pas trop mais ça
a été le but qui nous a vraiment libérés
du coup après on a essayé de poser la
balle pour jouer un match engagé puisque
un terrain praticable mais un bon match
dans l'ensemble on a su respecter les
consignes qui était donné une victoire 1
0 qui me semble mérité cette victoire
était également important sur le plan
comptable ce résultat permet à trèbes de
conserver son avance sur son adversaire
du jour
c'est assez serré au niveau des points
c'était un concurrent direct c'est avec
cette victoire est bon on aimait à cinq
points derrière nous du coup ça vous
soulager savoureux tira concurrents pour
le titre
à neuf journées de la fin du championnat
trap est toujours invaincu avec la
meilleure défense l'équipe pointe à la
deuxième place de régionale 3 on va
prendre les matches les uns après les
autres à la fin son dernier sprint y a
quelque chose à jouer à jouer bonjour à
fond à l'objectif ses premiers matches
après les autres et un président je
pense qu'en restant solides eux sera une
place intéressante en fin de saison
prochain match pour les trappistes ce
dimanche 17 février à domicile contre
franconville l'occasion d'étendre cette
série d'invincibilité à 14 matchs on
continue par du football et le
championnat de première division de
district plaisir est mort pas se sont
séparés sur un score nul et vierge 0 à 0
andré cours est monté son neutralisent 1
but partout le fc mantois et marly le
roi sont repartis dos à dos 2 partout le
chesnay remporté une précieuse précieuse
victoire sur le terrain de karajan
grésillons 1-0 sartrouville n'a pas fait
de détails en s'imposant 4 à 0 à
domicile contre gargenville le
championnat est toujours dominé par ou
qui n'a pas pu jouer ce week-end le choc
contre son dauphin à guyancourt
il y avait hâte également du football
mais cette fois ci
ricains ce week-end les templiers
d'elancourt ont enregistré leur
troisième victoire en trois matches dans
le championnat de 2e division
les élans courtois se sont imposés
samedi soir à domicile face aux myrmidon
de savigny-le-temple le score 26 à 7 une
victoire qui leur permet de prendre la
tête de la poule b de la conférence nord
on écoute le président des templiers
d'elancourt joël da silva matches trois
victoires donc pour l'instant on est
dans ned sur les objectifs fixés qui est
de se qualifier dans un premier temps
pour les play-offs
donc pour l'instant tout sans tous tout
s'emboîte correctement la semaine
prochaine on va à villeneuve d'ascq chez
les vikings de lille donc voilà pour
l'heure son tour tout est en ordre de
marche
après le foot us du rugby dans le
championnat honneur verseille n'en finit
plus de gagner 13 victoires en 13
matches pour les versaillais se sont
cette fois ci imposé dans la douleur sur
le terrain du rc paris 15 le score 15 à
11 pour les joueurs de la cité royale
qui reste en tête du classement avec
écoutez moi bien 21 points d'avancé sur
le second autant dire que la montée
n'est plus très loin pour les à
versailles est toujours dans le
championnat honneur mais cette fois ci
dans la poule 2 le sky rugby s'est
incliné sur le fil 16 à 15 sur son
terrain ce dimanche leurs bourreaux du
jour le fc vincennes au classement le
sky rugby est quasiment sûre et d'être
sauvé est sixième avec 30 points à
quatre points de la quatrième place
un étage plus bas dans le championnat de
promotion honneur laisse montigny le
bretonneux a remporté une précieuse
victoire à domicile contre son voisin le
rugby ces lois chesnaysiens le score 39
à 23
une victoire qui permet aux signé mon
teint d'être deuxièmes du championnat à
quatre points de la place de leader
détenu par aulnay chien nous allons
maintenant parler à biron thomas barrau
kramer licencié au cercle nautique de
versailles a réussi remporter la
médaille d'argent ce samedi 9 février au
stade charléty de paris sur 2000 mètres
lors des championnats de france indoor
qui a terminé à trois secondes 4 du
premier pierrot un pour nous parler de
cette performance et de ses objectifs de
la saison
nous recevons sur ce plateau thomas bach
ou bonsoir bonsoir alors est ce que vous
êtes satisfait de votre rentrée plutôt
oui la place
me met de fait dans les deux premiers et
donc les deux prétendants principaux
pour monter dans le bateau olympique le
chrono lui me laisse un petit peu
dubitatif
c'est un petit peu surpris du résultat
que je vois à la fin de la course il ya
quelques secondes de trop peu
insatisfait
alors je rappelle que la compétition
s'est fait sur des rameurs on va dire
statique
oui ça vaut ram habituel c'est la
discipline indoor c'est un peu
particulier c'est très différent de ce
qu'on a l'habitude de faire
c'est avant tout un effort physique bien
sûr qu'il ya un aspect technique qu'on
mettait quelqu'un qui a un novice sur un
rameur d'intérieur effectivement il a
des choses à apprendre pour que son
geste soit correcte mais pour nous il ya
beaucoup beaucoup moins d'un aspect
technique ce qu'il peut y avoir en
bateau on va dire qu'il n'y a quasiment
pas d'inconnus il n'y a pas de
paramètres extérieurs à gérer c'est
avant tout un effort physique
c'est plutôt un effort pour le chrono
finalement c'est très clairement un
effort pour le chrono surtout que c'est
vraiment un très très bon indicateur de
notre état de forme
ça vient vraiment valider le travail
hivernal qu'on a pu faire et voir si on
est dans les clous pour la suite de la
saison
justement est ce que vous pouviez faire
mieux oui clairement jeu j'espérais
faire mieux alors pas de beaucoup mais
j'étais à gagner entre une seconde et
demie et deux secondes par rapport aux
pruneaux que j'ai fait alors ça peut
sembler pas grand chose mais c'est quand
même très très compliqué d'aller
chercher ce genre de chrono
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que fur
et à mesure de la course coup par coup
je vous voyez à peu près le chiffre que
je voulais voir sur l'écran est donc en
droit le chrono à la fin je suis
vraiment très surpris je comprends pas
d'où il vient
j'ai pas eu accès aux chronos
intermédiaires les chronos sont toujours
pas en ligne un petit problème sur sur
notre série donc donc je sais pas si un
jour je comprendrais alors vous avez
perdu face à votre coéquipier pierre roy
en double poids légers en équipe de
france sur la saison dernière c'était
votre coéquipier ça sera également votre
coéquipier également sur la prochaine
saison alors je l'espère bien parce que
donc on est en plein milieu du processus
de sélection
qui va se terminer mi avril avec des
championnats de france en bateau cette
fois ci individuelle mais en bateau
pierre est champion de france donc sa
part être l'homme avec lequel il va
falloir compter
pour le reste de l'olympiade même c'est
l'homme de base du double est derrière
lui on essaie de trouver le coéquiper
qui fera en sorte que le bateau ait le
plus vite possible
donc si c'est moi ça veut dire que c'est
bien parti pour aller jusque jusqu'aux
championnats du monde dans un premier
temps et ensuite on espère des jo mais
faudra repasser par le même processus de
sélection des lauréats ont gagné vous
êtes plutôt optimiste je suis
raisonnablement optimiste et la route
est encore longue jusqu'à tokyo même si
elle a c'est à la fois proche est encore
très long il ya beaucoup d'entraînements
beaucoup d'heures à passer à
l'entraînement jusqu'aux jeux olympiques
il ya déjà un premier objectif cette
saison qui est qualifié le bateau et une
fois que ce sera fait on pourra se
projeter sur la suite et la saison
olympique
comment vous sentez-vous votre duo avec
pirmin alors on est assez différent de
base on n'a pas les mêmes morphotype je
suis un peu plus grand que lui il ya un
petit peu plus fort que moi physiquement
alors je compense par un peu plus de
d'endurance et de résistance
bon on a bien vu ce week-end qui était
quand même un petit peu plus fortement
encore ça me laisse une marge de
progression
on a aussi des façons drame est naturel
qu'ils sont un petit peu différente qui
nous demande beaucoup de travail
beaucoup de kilomètres et on commence à
avoir les fruits de notre travail on se
retrouve de plus en plus facilement plus
en plus rapidement quand on monte en
bateau ensemble on arrive à reproduire
de façon régulière
qu'on aime bien ce qu'il faut ce dont on
sait que ça fait régler le bateau vite
donc c'est assez positif et il n'y a pas
de raison qu'on continue par rapport au
passé sur cette voie là comment on fait
justement pour harmoniser un bateau deux
gabarits complètement différent c'est le
travail avant tout c'est beaucoup de
travail mais c'est aussi beaucoup de
communication
chacun a ses sensations chacun a sa
vision du geste et il faut échanger
beaucoup pour que justement on arrive à
trouver le compromis qui fait en sorte
que les deux arrivent à exploiter
pleinement pendant un effort
cueillez pas de doute qui aime
s'installer et c'est vraiment ce qu'on a
appris tout au long du championnat du
monde l'année dernière la préparation
pour les jeux olympiques ça débute sous
dès maintenant
ouais la préparation pour les jeux
olympiques elle a commencé j'allais dire
dès le début de la saison qui a suivi en
fête qui a suivi les précédentes aux
olympiques
c'est vraiment une construction sur
quatre ans il ya du travail personnel
il travail physique et technique
individuelle et ensuite faut mettre tout
ça dans le même bateau pour apprendre à
ramer de la même façon et être à 100%
tous les deux dans le cas qui nous
concerne pour faire en sorte que le
bateau ait le plus vite possible
alors vous êtes licencié au cercle
nautique de versailles depuis vos 12 ans
est ce que vous voulez leur ramener une
médaille d'or lors dès prochains g20
c'est pour ça que je m'entraîne toujours
ça vous motive également de ramener une
médaille pour votre club même si vous
aviez déjà remporté la médaille de
bronze
alors effectivement la médaille de
bronze est déjà là après je sais pas si
je le fais pour mon club
si je le fais pour moi je pense qu'avant
tout pour moi mais je le fais surtout
pas tellement pour le résultat ce plutôt
pour le plaisir que j'y prend jour après
jour
quel que soit le bateau quand je
m'entraîne seul avec un coéquipier avec
plusieurs coéquipiers aussi ça nous
arrive de monter dans les bateaux à 4
c'est vraiment voilà c'est vraiment ça
qui fait que je continue à m'entraîner
beaucoup de sacrifices quand même
beaucoup de d'investissement au
quotidien et
s'il n'y avait pas le plaisir ce serait
pas possible vous avez 31 ans 32 l'année
prochaine pour lors des jo
est ce que ça sera votre dernier défi ça
sera probablement effectivement mes
derniers jeux olympiques
aujourd'hui je n'envisage pas de
continuer jusqu'en 2024 pense que j'ai
vécu des championnats du monde en france
donc c'était déjà extraordinaire je
pense que des jeux olympiques à la
maison c'est juste incroyable à vivre
mais clairement ça fera un peu loin pour
moi
donc sauf vraiment changement incroyable
ce seront mes derniers jeux olympiques
merci d'être passé sur ce plateau thomas
barrau bon courage pour la suite de
votre saison
on suivra votre année avec attention
comme d'habitude sur tv 78 merci
beaucoup merci à vous un mode handball à
présent chez les féminines en nationale
2 montigny le bretonneux a subi un coup
d'arrêt ce week-end invaincu en 2019
lésigny montaigne se sont inclinés 31 27
à domicile contre heureuse entre du 29
au classement montigny le bretonneux est
toujours septième avec un bilan à
l'équilibré de six victoires pour 6
défaites
chez les garçons dans le championnat de
nationale 3 plaisir a subi une nouvelle
défaite à l'extérieur cette fois ci sur
le teint de montfermeil
le leader du championnat les isérois
s'incline 33-29 et restent dixièmes sur
12 équipes engagées
ce résultat confiant que plaisir devra
se battre jusqu'au bout pour le maintien
on reste à plaisir pour parler sport de
combat et plus précisément de karaté le
maître naoki omis est venue enseigner
ses techniques de combat ce samedi à
plaisir lors d'un stage organisé par le
karaté club plaisir oit une cinquantaine
de personnes a participé à ce rendez
vous un montage de sandrine fonteilles
des images de grégory canada après même
en a seulement coup dopé
ces balades tout autre invité de marque
à plaisir m naoki omis 8e dan de karaté
était présent ce samedi 9 février au
palais des sports
le karatéka est restée cinq heures sur
place pour animer un stage organisé par
le karaté club plaisir ouah je transmets
pas mafieux des leur vie assez les mêmes
techniques technique se déplacer
dépassement parce que karaté on est pas
qu accorde encore pour toucher il faut
souder pas s'ils vont très vite l on
écoute pas copé le rendez-vous a permis
à une cinquantaine de participants venus
de plaisir de ses environs de découvrir
une nouvelle approche de cet art martial
japonais
il est 8ème d'années il est ceinture
noire aussi
il vient du japon je crois oui et donc
au japon c'est pas la même chose je
pense
il nous apporte un savoir-faire des
techniques des gestes qui sont
extrêmement importants pour nous
simplement de façon très simple et très
ludiques philosophiques m naoki omi a
également profité de ce rendez-vous pour
revenir sur l'impact de l'âge dans le
monde du sport et notamment sur le
karaté ou est en jaune on est un peu
fougueux et en vieillissant bien on
adapte en fonction de sa morphologie de
sa santé mais par contre notre technique
va s'affiner et a de plus en plus
efficaces m e now qui dit régulièrement
sans le trahir
il dit souvent je je suis moon ou plus
puissant qu'avant je fais moins
d'efforts qu'avant après m'être now qui
ont mis un nouvel expert national en
karaté devrait revenir à plaisir le 18
mai prochain
on continue à parler de sport de combat
coup de projecteur sur le club de
taekwondo de trappes une structure qui
arrive à sortir des jeunes talents
chaque année nous recevons sur ce
plateau le directeur technique jawad
chewbacca l'ida haddad junior première
année louis georges aura je n'ai pas
écorcher c'est ça voilà seigneur
première année le président ian burel
vont soir bonsoir
alors avant de parler du club on va
parler de taekwondo qu'est ce que c'est
pour les personnes qui ne connaissent
pas encore le taekwondo le taekwondo
c'est un art martial coréen qui datent
du début 1900 rigueur d'après guerre qui
est sport olympique depuis depuis 2000
4 à athènes je crois même de 1000 à 2000
ou assassinés parmi les civils ça a été
un sport de démonstration à séoul en 94
voilà ça c'est pour ceux qui connaissent
pas ça en sommes au karaté là sauf qu'il
ya beaucoup plus de technique de gens
c'est assez spectaculaire
comme vous pouvez voir sur la photo et
quelques ajustements donc voilà alors
président pourquoi ça fonctionne aussi
bien en club de taekwondo de trappes
c'est une bonne question je rappelle
quand même voilà récemment au tournoi à
venir occitania rodez sur douze
compétiteurs présents neuf sont revenus
avec des médailles aux championnats de
france espoirs deux compétiteurs ont
décroché des médailles
comment expliquez vous ces bons
résultats mal la jeunesse dynamique de
la vie déjà c'est vrai qu'on a un vivier
attrape important beaucoup de jeunes
natifs de la ville beaucoup d'énergie
donc ça nous amène un vivier régulier
pour pour la pratique du sport
après la dynamique du club instaurée
depuis quelques années la dynamique
instaurée par jaouad ici qui organise
beaucoup de déplacements ou beaucoup de
compétitions pour les jeunes pour qu'ils
puissent acquérir malgré leur jeune âge
déjà une belle expérience donc khalid à
qui et qui a déjà quelques années
derrière elle a déjà fait beaucoup de
compétition louis qui est un peu plus
jeunes dans le club a déjà aussi pas mal
pas mal tourné au niveau national donc
c'est aussi une des clés donc beaucoup
faire des changes beaucoup faire bouger
les jeunes qu'ils puissent acquérir une
expérience rapidement louis qu'est ce
qui vous a séduit dans le projet de
trappes
d'abord c'est l'implication des coachs
en fait ce qui nous suivent au quotidien
vraiment à l'entraînement ils vont
réussir à faire ressortir cette partie
ne qui va nous permettre d'exceller par
la suite décroché des médailles et aussi
l'implication qui met dans les
déplacements à travers le club
je trouve ça va
c'est gratifiant parce qu'ils se
déplacent ils prennent du temps dans
leur vie pour qu'au final on puisse nous
réussir et on voit que ça paye donc ça
fait toujours plaisir
rallye la même chose c'est d'abord
remercier mes cause puisque ils ont
toujours été derrière moi m'ont fait
ressortir mes qualités aussi mes défauts
pour ensuite réussir dans les
compétitions javani voilà un petit peu
moins de travail lors des prochains
entraînements apparemment ouais je crois
bien mais bon comme ils disent
on les suit on essaie de faire des
entraînements
profil vous adaptez les séances en
fonction du profil
oui oui beaucoup il ya vraiment un suivi
on essaie de parler avec les ânes ce
qu'on pourrait améliorer ou pas et ça
leur a réussi ils ont réussi à faire des
podiums en championnat de france et on
espère qu'ils vont pas s'arrêter là
alors vous avez sorti des jeunes pépites
comme l'escrimé bas ou encore et yanis
gomis dans le passé comment comment on
fait pour aussi régulièrement en sortir
finalement des talents je pense que
c'est la dynamique globale c'est vrai
que c'est important d'avoir des leaders
sportifs les premiers qui font des
résultats ouvrent les portes
giresse et qu'une fois où on a toujours
un peu le complexe et parfois de la
réussite et le fait qu'ils aient déjà eu
des résultats aussi ça décomplexe les
suivants c'est à dire que moi aussi je
veux accéder à ce niveau de performance
et donc je vais me donner les moyens
pour faire comme les grands et moi aussi
servi ses hôtels à fond de verre qui a
été brisée peut-être avec c je pense que
ça donne ça peut jouer avec why do it a
fait tout à fait râler est ce que ça
vous mortiers vous de voir des sportifs
réussir nous pousse vers la réussite lui
même chose bien sûr quand on voit que
les jeunes qui viennent du même milieu
que nous conte ils les mêmes conditions
d'entraînement que nous peuvent peuvent
réussir on se dit que rien n'est
impossible pour nous et forcément ça
motive
jawad a également sa part de
responsabilité dans la réussite du club
président oui tout à fait on parlait
tout à l'heure d'investissements des
coachs jawad est un bon exemple
puisqu'il s'investir vient tout juste de
turquie où là encore emmener des jeunes
en déplacement je crois que depuis le
début d'année il ya peut-être eu un
week-end et encore où il n'est pas ou
n'a pas été en déplacement
donc oui ça demande beaucoup
d'investissements parce que lui aussi
une vie de famille
il consacre beaucoup de temps à d'autres
enfants qui sont un peu nos enfants mais
voilà qui me auxquels on constate quand
même beaucoup de temps dernière question
président est ce que vous voulez
continuer sur cette politique de
formation
bien sûr nous l'objectif c'est former
les jeunes leur permettre d'intégrer
après des structures plus importantes
comme on l'a fait avec nisreen débarque
intégrer un prêt paul à fontainebleau
donc c'est ça le ce que nous on a nos
limites en tant que qu'association pour
encadrer et accompagner les jeunes
jusqu'au plus haut niveau après des
structures nationales qui sont là pour
ça aussi
le prochain rendez vous pour ces jeunes
jawad pour ces jeunes c'est dans deux
semaines tournois à venir de paris qui a
un parcours de positionnement pour
intégrer l'équipe de france et faire des
déplacements
merci à vous mais passé sur ce plateau
n'hésitez pas à nous solliciter si vous
organisez notre événement voilà c'est
aussi et deux médailles chez les jeunes
pépites de trappes merci beaucoup
avant de passer à notre chronique junior
cap sur la colline d'elancourt à l'appel
à projets a été lancé pour aménager le
site en vue des prochains jeux
olympiques de 2024 la colline haute de 2
131 mètres va accueillir les épreuves de
vtt sur ces 52 hectares conformément au
cahier des charges olympiques les
tribunes pouvant accueillir 3000
spectateurs vont être créés 20000 places
ont aussi créé le long du parcours le
projet devra également prendre en compte
la presse jeux olympiques les candidats
ont jusqu'au 4 mars pour participer à
cet appel à projets le lauréat sera
connu d'ici à la fin de l'année le sien
comme chaque mois nous recevons sur ce
plateau mélanie poké notre chroniqueuse
qui nous présente à chaque fois des
rendez vous pour les juniors alors
aujourd'hui ce soir en mélange l'art et
le sport avec la natation synchronisée
oui c'est un sport
connus dont on parle en général qu'au
moment des jeux olympiques mais à vélizy
villacoublay un câble enseigne cette
discipline il accueille les enfants dès
l'âge de 3 ans les entraînements ont
lieu tous les samedis midi une heure de
kourou bien sûr la première leçon c'est
d'apprendre à nager
puis les entraînements s'allonge ça
passe à trois heures avec le mercredi et
les plus grandes travail qu'elle après
quasiment chaque jour de la semaine
écoutez aurélie l'une des entraîneurs du
club
à nous avons un petit
avec le régime en tout cas ce qu'elle
dit dans une interview c'est que c'est
un sport qui demande beaucoup
d'engagement de rigueur aurélie parle
voilà de travail musculaire
d'assouplissement ce qu'elles ont un
travail à sec elles sont pas tout de
suite dans l'eau bien sûr mais pas de
panique la compétition peut se faire dès
6 ans les peu les plus jeunes vont faire
des petits exercices les nageuses ne
font pas tout de suite les figures
parfois spectaculaires des plus grandes
comme on peut le voir souvent dans les
compétitions mais il ya tout de même à
la fin d'année le gala c'est surtout une
initiation à la natation synchronisée
saint fort pour les jeunes filles en
tout cas qui est très complet parce
qu'on leur demande à la fois d'être
gracieuse on leur demande d'avoir la
force on lors il ya une écoute musicale
il ya aussi le fait d'être en équipe
c'est quelque chose qui est un cas
intéressant alors vous l'aurez peut-être
remarqué j'ai beaucoup utilisé le mot
elle mais il faut savoir que la natation
synchronisée est bien sûr ouvert ouverte
aux garçons
le club de vie lisez vous attend donc
pour les garçons et pour les filles
merci beaucoup mélanie on vous
retrouvera le mois prochain pour une
nouvelle chronique consacrée au sport
pour les petits sien on passe maintenant
notre page agenda
[Musique]
on ouvre cette page agenda par une
course insolite la 10e édition du no
petit raid est programmée ce samedi soir
à 21h dans la vallée de chevreuse au
départ de bures-sur-yvette ce raid
nocturne de 60 km est composé de cinq
sports vtt trail bike and run biathlon
et course d'orientation
chaque équipe sera composée de trois
participants regarde le de suite le
teaser de l'événement
[Musique]
et
plus d'informations sur le no petit raid
sur le site qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
une autre course va rythmer le
département ce week-end le 38e cross de
la sablière se déroulera ce dimanche 17
février à partir de 9h30 au programme
cinq courses par catégorie d'âge des
poussins aux vétérans
le rendez vous phare sera un cross long
de 11 km avec des dénivelés dans la
forêt de meudon et de versailles les
départs de viroflay les organisateurs
attendent plus de 500 participants sur
cette course
au programme également ce samedi
dimanche du tir à l'arc les archers de
bus en co organise le championnat
régional adultes de tir à l'arc en salle
le rendez-vous sera organisé au gymnase
maurice baquet de 8 heures à 22 heures
30 le samedi et de 9h 30 à 16 heures 45
le dimanche plus de trois cents archers
classé parmi les meilleurs en île de
france seront présents pour cet
événement
leur objectif se préparer en vue d'un
futur championnat de france
st il y aura également du football
américain ce week-end ce samedi à 18
heures les moins de 16 ans des templiers
d'elancourt reçoivent les cougars
gaulois de l'entente saint-ouen-l'aumône
sannois un adversaire à leur portée
classé pour le moment à la dernière
place de la poule a du championnat si
vous voulez les soutenir la rencontre
est programmée au complexe sportif
europe un mot de boxe à présent le grand
jour approche pour marvin petit le
boxeur de la team farrugia est en cours
et dans la dernière ligne droite de sa
préparation pour aller chercher un titre
de champion de france d'europe des poids
légers sur les terres du belge francesco
patera ce samedi 6 février les avantages
pour marine petit léger avantage pour
marine petit le sportif de 27 ans
affiche pour le moment un bilan de 24
victoires dont 12 par ko 1 nul et une
défaite
son adversaire affiche hui 20 victoires
pour trois défaites
on termine par du cyclisme sur piste la
sélection pour les championnats prochain
aux championnats du monde sera dévoilée
ce mercredi au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
on devrait retrouver dans cette liste
sauf grosse surprise sébastien vigier
reillanne est la nouvelle pépite du
cyclisme féminin mathilde de gros ou
encore grégory baugé
la compétition est programmé du 27
février au 3 mars à pruszkow en pologne
la france tentera d'y faire bonne figure
avant les jeux olympiques de tokyo
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]